important Singapore heard that Teo a 19
year old art student died after taking
MDMA with her 18 year old schoolmate
rajiel Putra Setia sukumarajana wow you
had a truck you had a problem with
Felicia and that you just nailed yeah
what the [ __ ] I've got a problem with
you right now
ball
[Laughter]
[Music]
s
all right so this right here
sweet Felicia tail tea Felicia oh
Felicia Felicia Felicia
yes
that's a nice jawline first of all yeah
very sharp I don't know where you're
trying to lead me down yes this is a
kind of weird path you want to go on
Anthony okay well that's Felicia tail
because it looks like a MySpace picture
of my space picture yeah for all you old
heads out there she disappeared uh and
uh her disappearance was a mystery right
The Disappearance of Felicia Felicia why
do I keep saying that Felicia Felicia
was a mystery that tortured her family
and puzzled Singapore for more than a
decade
say it just say it no come on go ahead
no go ahead she had a very insensitive
joke no Ryan this is why you're here
Colleen appearing people Anthony they
were talking about Felicia and her
disappearance
bye Felicia oh no oh no I guess that's
what you told me I mean it's either that
or r.i.p's bye is a little nicer it is
nicer it is nicer you know it wasn't as
bad as I thought I wasn't as bad as I
thought but I was expecting worse still
good though still good so when she
disappeared it's a mystery 16 years
since she vanished the truth about
Taylor's disappearance came to light in
Court Justice last week wow told by one
of two men she was with on the night she
went missing revealing an elaborate
cover a cover-up about her death okay
the court in Singapore heard that Teo a
19 year old art student died after
taking MDMA with her 18 year old school
mate rajiel Putra Setia sukumarajana wow
you had a truck you had a problem with
Felicia and that you just nailed yeah
what the [ __ ] I've got a problem with
you right now
ball
[Laughter]
it [ __ ] Nails [ __ ] crazy ass dude
that was like five names oh that was
like five that was like five diseases
did you ever have a dream that you wish
hey guys this is supposed to be a sad
story
we have a part yeah we're trying to
stall right now all right
so uh yeah back to you no just kidding
okay man no that was the other guy's
name so 18 year old school
and 22 year old graphic designer Ahmad
Daniel Muhammad Rafael okay
two threes back to back
pulling up from half Al Fishman all of a
sudden right here I'm right here okay so
the two men
the two men burned her body oh and
misled investigators okay the court
heard as they feared punishment for
taking the controlled substance in
Singapore so that'll get you killed
anyway oh right yeah they're dead which
holds some of the world's harshest drugs
or drug laws okay
on Friday Ahmad Daniel was sentenced to
26 months in jail after pleading guilty
to fabricating false evidence providing
the police with false evidence
misappropriating Tales belongings and
unlawfully depositing her corpse okay
Roger the other guy an Indonesian
citizen remains at Large
however Ahmad Daniel will likely be
released soon after factoring remission
the court herd as the Now 37 year old
has spent more than 18 months in remand
since he was arrested in 2020. the pair
had gotten away with it for 13 years
until New Evidence surfaced in 2020
which sent authorities down a rabbit
hole to uncover what happened in the
early hours of June 30th 2007.
the trio had returned to Original's flat
to consume ecstasy after a party and
sometime between 6 a.m Ahmad Daniel and
rajio realized that Teo had died of an
unknown cause whoa
which obviously if you're like [ __ ]
on drugs and you're just in the middle
of the night and then somebody like oh
Deez or dies something like that yeah
you know and then you're also in
Singapore and you know that if you're
[ __ ] caught with doing any drug yeah
not not trying to like obviously
humanize it empathize but at the same
time like I can only imagine the type of
panic and uh just yeah desperate to
avoid being caught for drug consumption
which would even face jail terms of up
to 18 months per um the pair decides to
dispose of her body oh my God
hiding Tales body between two mattresses
they cleaned the flap before planting
her phone at a park for police to find
they then bought tools to dispose of her
body before returning home where they
put Teo in a box and sealed it with tape
they transported the box out of the flat
using the staircase to avoid security
cameras before taking a cab to a remote
location on the outskirts of Singapore
there the man put the box into a hole
they dug doused in kerosene and set it
on fire once the Flames burnt out they
covered the hole
teo's mother would Lodge a police report
for her missing daughter on July 3rd and
when contacted by police Ahmad Daniel
and Reginald fed them alive that they
had agreed on Teo had left the unit at
around 2 30 a.m to meet someone at East
Coast Park the location where they had
left her phone and they had not seen her
since Ahmad Daniel who made two sets of
false statements during the
investigation told police that Teo had
stormed out of the flat with her laptop
and bag after he told her to silence her
phone which was ringing loudly while she
texted he also said that she left after
he called her a [ __ ] for having
multiple boyfriends no further
investigations were conducted against
the parent 2007 uh seven amid a lack of
evidence suggesting Foul Play on their
part however authorities regularly
reviewed her case for leads and kept in
touch with her family
the sun disappearance the tail made
waves in the city-state with almost 200
of her friends and family Distributing
Flyers around to find her her parents
even visited the neighboring Malaysian
city of Johor Bahru to look for her
local media reported made me attention
on Taylor's case her family and friends
also fell victim to prank calls
promising Intel on her whereabouts so
basically they like kind of went the
distance and like sometimes we like read
about [ __ ] people that are trying to
like you know cover up their murders and
stuff like that 99 out of 100 times kind
of dumb something like doesn't really
like work out there's like they're very
thorough of these guys yeah but I think
once I read the idea of even like
putting the phone at a certain place and
fabricating a lie that both of them
would swear to and then saying and
misleading the cops in a certain way to
the point where they didn't have enough
evidence suggesting foul play on the two
and it actually worked yeah worked
they're just racing average Asians
though exactly
Asians are really smart so if you're
[ __ ] I think yeah if you get like
straight A's all the time how do you
think you're gonna cover up a crime
probably a plus you know what's sad is
that that's kind of true really you've
got two dumbasses if I'm failing all
their classes they're probably gonna be
sleeping with the evidence like on their
body and then [ __ ] I don't know
because she was dead and they're flat
huh yeah that is true though like you
you think about this is a [ __ ]
affluent country they're probably high
income family at least if they can
[ __ ] survive potentially yeah they're
probably smarter than the average person
in general yeah one of our friends who
went to jail and end up going to ivy
league university for his master's
degree
when he was in gangs he was like Hey
we're going to break into all these
homes why don't we just start buying all
the locks from Home Depot and start
practicing
you know so like business so like the
brains is just operating at a higher
level
than someone that's I don't know if I
can do it rather than a guy that just
like goes up to homeowner and demands
entry shoots him on a botched robbery
goes instantly to jail yeah that's it
yeah well this guy must have not gotten
Straight A's
there might have been a b in there
somewhere it's a cool case how did they
get caught the Cold Case was revived in
2020 when police found that Ahmad Daniel
had taken possession of teo's laptop and
given it to his father
and he said he said that she took it
with him
that might be a c bro right it's hard
okay
foreign
why do you look like an exterminator you
could hang in here for now okay
nice to meet you hello Walter how are
you how's Walter can you use recipe no
no I'm good okay say that to the camera
look at the camera say it's a camera
look at it that's off camera no no this
is gonna be in the edit yeah that's a
that's a flub you can't make mistakes
like that that's a bad mistake yo like
why would you keep the laptop like for
years especially if that's in your
statement if you if you memorize all the
Beats of your statement the way these
smart Asian kids did they would know
that like I said they she took her
laptop and then you give it to your pops
yeah that's kind of a stupid thing to do
yeah so my Danielle was then arrested
after confessing to lying during the
initial investigation after his arrest
authorities conducted screenings on
skeletons found in the area where teo's
body was abandoned and concluded via DNA
testing that an unidentified partial
human skull discovered in 2010 likely
belonged to two none of her other
remains were discovered in the vicinity
you know what's pretty crazy though it
it's always fascinating to me how you
can go from having no priors to suddenly
having the gall to chop a body up yeah
that's pretty impressive it's wild
because that's not something you you
know suddenly you're just a [ __ ]
Stater Brothers meat man like that's
really [ __ ] extreme to having no
other like you've never you've never
done anything and it's like it's like an
eight-part uh eight step process too
right you don't just happen to have
[ __ ] the right knives or bags or [ __ ]
you have to like consciously get out of
panic clean your [ __ ] up go to like a
store to pick up supplies and check out
at a register still come home with the
grits and think that you're gonna do
this another [ __ ] bottle without then
to do it well without breaking down
without even you gotta like take apart
cartilage and stuff you don't even just
like trying to cut a chicken apart it's
[ __ ] hard already holy [ __ ] put on a
[ __ ] VPN when you're Googling how to
get rid of blood on your car that's what
all always like [ __ ] it it gets to me
it's like wow The psychosis of
desperation must kick in so [ __ ] and
hard that suddenly you're able to do the
most insane things just to like get out
of it I always wonder why people spend
the energy doing that versus using all
that brain power and then like just
trying to flee the country or something
yeah you know like for me I'm like if
someone died in my house
like instead of like trying to like make
it look like nothing happened I'd be
like I'd try to make it look like I
never even existed oh it's [ __ ]
bounce the country or do some other [ __ ]
yeah like you bounced on especially make
it look like you just were never there
to begin with yeah yeah yeah that's a
good move so Ahmad Danielle's lawyer
said that he will be appealing for a
discharge amounting to acquittal and his
mitigation plea he expressed deep regret
for his actions and said that he had
thought the surrendering uh or he
thought about surrendering to the police
on multiple occasions now this is an
interesting part his lawyers painted him
as young man trying to avoid drug
charges Singapore's Zero Tolerance
policy which can see people given the
death penalty for carrying just 500
grams of cannabis has faced growing
scrutiny from local activists and
international human rights groups so
there is a little bit of a conversation
not full on blowing debate or anything
like that but there is like a uh you
know this is kind of like like proof
that sometimes people will go to like
really horrendous links because of the
drug laws that are already in place that
put yourself in that situation you know
yeah that's a thought you would rather
not like maybe they could have saved a
life maybe she OD'd and she wasn't dead
but they didn't want to call the
ambulance because they were afraid all
of them are just going to go down yeah
versus just like thinking hey what's the
first thing I should do try and save her
life you know what I mean yeah yeah that
is true but also Singapore is doing so
well I wouldn't change a thing sure like
they're smoking everybody and they're
smaller than Los Angeles County yeah wow
think
Nick
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]